[Music]
hey how you guys doing hey good to be
here it's nice to be here again I like
performing here it's not too swanky you
know I hate before him plays it at real
swanky I did a show yesterday at a place
with a bathroom attendant yeah yeah I
had a fun moment I walked in the
bathroom attendant peeing the tables
have turned
so I go up behind him with a paper towel
I hand it to him I wait for a tip he
looks at me like I'm crazy and I went
exactly
flew here yesterday I hate flying let's
the only part of this job I hate I like
a train
give me an Amtrak any day huh no bag
check no security it's amazing I hate
flying flying it's so high-maintenance
flies like a high-maintenance chick like
you want to get inside me got here an
hour early take his shoes off and do a
body scan not a train it trains like a
drunk chick like get a beer
[Applause]
no security on the train whatsoever you
can walk on a train with three suitcase
full of cocaine like hey if you see
something say something
this is how sad and lonely trains are
trains don't ask to see your ticket
until the train has left the station
they've already started moving and then
they ask how much could they really care
tickets please I don't have one we gotta
buy one now I know many money we'll
figure it out yeah I was a hungover on
the flight I drink too much I'm what you
call a function alcoholic any function
holics there no functional hood we get a
bad rap oh you don't we're actually
harder working and everyone else we're
doing the same stuff you're doing drunk
right where's our parade what Bob showed
up to work on time screw Bob I slept
here feel like you got a drink now that
the news is crazy so much stuff going on
a lot of racial stuff oh yeah I'm not
racist I look at racism the same way I
look at Nickelback yeah it's fun to joke
about but uh you never want to see it
live
I don't know I feel like you can't
really be racist these days you lose
your job you make headlines you get
ostracized from society it's very risky
to be racist nowadays that's why if
anyone's ever racist around you now you
know they trust you it's kind of this
weird bittersweet moment you know if
you're gonna smoke break with some guys
like man I can't stand Mexicans you're
like holy hell you're full of hate but I
didn't know we were so close I grew up
in the south - I've seen some crazy
stuff I grew up this guy hates
minorities hates them all Jewish black
Mexican Asian whatever but he just had a
baby which I find strange cuz babies and
minorities have all the same negative
stereotypes if you hate minorities you
date babies - let me think about it
babies are loud movie theaters I can't
swim they all look alike lazy they don't
work they can't drive they never tip
yeah they come to this country not
knowing the language you can almost hear
the blogs heating up a single guy back
on the scene always bring your own
condom that's what I say sir yeah I
fooling around the girl recently she
goes hey t of a condom I said I forgot
she goes I might have one she starts
thinking through her stuff she finds one
Magnum oh dammit this went from a good
time to a challenge alright well let's
give it a whirl why not so she ripped it
open she rolled it on and it fit it fit
and I gotta tell you people that is a
man's version of Cinderella right there
yeah single my last girlfriend dumped me
said I wasn't manly enough for her not a
manly guy that one hurt yeah I didn't
know when we're allowed to say stuff
like that like I'm all about equality
but how got woman can say something like
yeah like guy was good with his hands he
can fix stuff around the house and
you're like alright cool but if a guy
says hey I like a woman who can cook
people go woah woah it's not the 50s
well how come her Jeremy's okay my
jabber is okay
also who doesn't like somebody can fix
stuff around the house I'd love to come
home my girlfriend's like hey I built a
deck see I think women are really smart
because you guys made your gender roles
offensive that was very clever
well-played ladies well played guys how
great would that be if we get offended
now your girlfriend wakes up at 4:00
a.m. I heard glass shattering somebody
break in you're like well it's not the
fifties go check it out
[Applause]
right now
that's hilarious Thank You Marvin
ladies
that is our show good anime
[Applause]